فيديو
[موسيقى]
فقط على
الرئيس الفرنسيه
مع مجموعه كبيره من المسؤولين هو انني
اتطلع لتعزيز هذه المحادثات شكرا
لوجود هنا بصفه اول رئيس اقوله اقوم بهذه
الزياره فمن خلال همم هذه الزياره التي
تعكس مدى عمق علاقاتنا وصداقتنا هناك جمله
من المواضيع التي
نعتزم مناقشتها في ظل هذه الاوقات الصعبه
منها الحرب الروسيه في اوكرانيا هذا سوف
يكون اول الموضوع على نقاشا لنا وهو منذ
بدايه هذه الحرب كنا قد عملنا بصوره لسيقه
وعلى دعم اوكرانيا لزقاوم وللتتحلى بالقوه
ومن خلال فرض العقوبات على رؤوسه لكن ما
نؤده ايضا
ان نشيده بالتصريحات الكثيره التي همم قمت
بالتعبير عنها نود ان
تنعم اوكرانيا بالسلام او اسياد الكامله
الخاصه بها وفي ذات الوقت
لتحقيق السلام المستدامه على المدى الطويل
وانا ملتزم بهذا الامر
وسوف نناقشه ايضا مساء
تتعلق بالطاقه والفضاء
وكيفيه تعزيزي هذه المسائل من خلال
التنسيق التنسيقي في ما بيننا
رغم وجودي
عده اختلافات
هذه الحرب التي تطال شعوبنا وفي ذلك الوقت
اعدادا المستقبليه
اللي همم
بطريقه تعزز الاقتصاد وخلق اعداد كبيره من
المواضيع الوظائف واللذا لابد من تصديق
جهودنا في هذا الاتجاه لان هذا موضوع
مهم في نقاشه وسوف نتطرق ايضا الى التنوع
البيولوجي
وبعض المواضيع التي تتصدر الساحه العالميه
كلها مهم لكن اود ان اشكركم مره اخرى
واشكره السيده الاولى على عمق صداقه وعلى
مدى جوده هذه النقاشات والقرارات المشتركه
التي سوف يتم اتخاذها في هذا الخصوص في
هذه الاوقات الصعبه
فان هذه الصداقه دائما هي التي تسود
واثمرت بنتائج طيبه بالمناسبه
[موسيقى]
منور منور
كما تعلمون سوف نجري مؤتمرا صحفيا لذا سوف
نجيب على اسئلتكم في خلال ذلك المؤتمر
الصحفي بعد قليل